all right people of the internet we are
live on rumble blaze tv and i think
we're still on youtube i'm dave rubin
this is the reuben report direct message
and it is friday and we are bringing
back the friday all-star panel joining
me today
are the host of unapologetic live on
prageru amila ekpanobi host of the young
heretics show spencer clavin and a
writer speaker and mad mama alicia
krauss amela spencer alicia welcome back
to the reuben report thank you to be
here thanks for having us good to have
you guys one of you alicia in la a
second one of you amela in l.a and a
third of you spencer a former la guy now
in nashville and the theme of the show
and of course i'm a former la guy now in
the free state of florida the theme of
the show today is going to be that we're
winning i think some good things are
happening i think you guys are all right
in the thick of it and that's what we're
going to be covering today obviously
some of the roe v wade stuff elon
musk now is going to be the ceo of
twitter like he's really going all in on
this thing and uh you may remember that
orange man donald trump well 22 of his
22 candidates that he endorsed all won
uh their elections in the last couple
days before we get to any of that though
i want to talk to you guys about real
estate agents i trust
you guys know that buying or selling a
home is already one of the most
stressful things you can do and it can
be 10 times worse if you're not working
with the right agent generally speaking
our homes are our biggest investment
that's a lot of responsibility and you
need an agent who takes that seriously
that's why i recommend real estate
agents i trust founded by my by my good
buddy glenn beck they work with only the
best agents in every market they do
their homework talking to every agent
before inviting them to join their
network and here's a big one they only
work with full-time professionals no
part-time or inexperienced agents their
team makes the intro and then follows
you through the buying or selling
process to make sure that you're
satisfied
partnered with the blaze the agents they
work with have a long track record and
are best sellers in their field they're
part of this audience they share your
values and they're almost anywhere you
want to go especially florida people
it's pretty good here the process is
simple
just go to real estate agents
itrust.com today and pro provide us with
some basic info that's real estate
agents
itrust.com their team will contact you
to make an intro to their preferred
agent in your town and now back to me
all right guys so obviously the big
story this week i emailed it to you in
case you hadn't heard about it on the
twitter uh is this
this briefing that got leaked it does
look like roe v wade is going to be
flipped that will of course kick
abortion back to the states just a
little info here from politico the
supreme court has voted to strike down
roe v wade according to an initial draft
majority opinion written by justice
samuel alito and obtained by politico
we hold that row and casey must be
overruled alito writes so we've got some
video of elizabeth warren going
completely bananas but before we get to
that guys
um
i'll start with you first uh let's just
talk about the leak for a second
are we already past the point where
we're going to figure out who the leaker
was or does anyone even care anymore i
mean it seems like such
a crazy extraordinary escalation of just
the general state of everything
collapsing at once
but we need to find out who it is right
oh i completely agree there needs to be
a full-scale investigation launched on
this and that was something that i
harked on when this first came out is
that guys we're not supposed to be
seeing this this is completely unethical
and it's undermining the only
institution that we really have left to
trust or had left to trust and i was
wondering you know what's going to be
the next issue there's got to be a next
issue they didn't win with the whole
don't say gay thing they didn't win with
the crt they're not winning with climate
change because it's too distant from us
and it had to be something and this was
their most immediate push that they
could have but we need to find out who
did this because again it's a complete
undermining of this uh established
institution that we've had so much trust
in
spencer imagine
yeah
well can you imagine if this had been in
a conservative direction this week i
mean remember january 6 our norms the
insurrection the attempt to undermine a
free and fair democratic process what
amal is saying is exactly right if
anything represents an attempted
insurrection or an attempt to interfere
with a serious democratic process i mean
it's it's this and you there would be
you know investigations there would be
persecutions prosecutions and nothing i
mean a little bit the courts
whoever this leaker is i don't know for
some reason i think it's a dude he will
get a professorship
league law school like yale or harvard
and then he'll get an instant msnbc
contributorship for life i mean but had
this been someone on the other side to
spencer's point i don't think it would
be so cushy
so let's just talk about the actual
content of it because
i've
by the nature of my job every now and
again i have to watch these cnn and
msnbc clips and they're quite horrific
uh but when you watch what what
mainstream is saying about this the
implication is that abortion is now
going to be illegal that of course as
you guys know and as my whole audience
knows that is not what this is about
it's about kicking it back to the states
we know that most states are going to
have legal abortion they're going to
have some restrictions and there might
be a small amount of states that
absolutely outlaw it and maybe some will
have you know minor restrictions related
to rape or incest or the health of the
mother et cetera et cetera
but is this just a perfect example of
how we can't get anything done right
anymore because nobody trusts the media
and there are just half half the
countries basically brainwashed into
thinking that this is about abortion
being taken away altogether and that uh
you know hands made tale is now a
reality show alicia
yeah absolutely i mean i've seen so many
celebrities and memes out there um
trending on social media even posted by
friends of mine that i'm like no this is
actually not true uh credit to lila rose
live action because they've been
counteracting a lot of the mistruths
about this out there including that
ectopic pregnancy which requires a
medical dnc is not abortion guys and
it's not going to be outlawed when
something like that is crucial to the
life of the mother it's still going to
occur and it is not the same of actually
ending a baby's life you know smushing
them inside their mother's womb and then
vacuuming them out um when it is a
viable human being and so there's just a
lot of mistruths out there and i'm like
i'd love to have a conversation about
reproductive rights since that's what
planned parenthood and radical leftists
claim to be for let's talk about how the
reproductive rights of and medical
rights of women were
crucially infringed over the last two
years and from the same people that are
shouting my body my choice are ignoring
i don't know female disney employees and
others who are saying don't want a
vaccine that i don't think should be
forced on me i mean we can go like toe
to toe on this all day long but they
don't want to talk about the actual
details of it all they just want to
pretend that republicans are all big bad
guys that want women to die in back
alleys amela alicia mentions radical
leftists you like me maybe more than me
you were a radical leftist not too long
ago um yeah are you are you surprised
how all in they're going on abortion
right now meaning the left basically
there's almost no democrat politician
including joe biden at this point who is
saying that there should be any limits
on abortion that's what the new bill
that chuck schumer is pushing right now
that they will fully leave it up to the
mental and physical health of the woman
which means you could be eight months
pregnant and just say hey i don't want
to be pregnant anymore and they will
allow it we know that new york has
already passed laws related to all this
are you surprised that there's just like
like that's the extreme position uh but
there's nobody there's just nobody left
right on the democrat side that's gonna
reel this thing in right i'm not
surprised by this at all for the
politicians and elites i think it's this
last last-ditch effort before this next
election cycle to sort of hone it in and
get these young women voters to get
involved as far as your average day
leftists which i used to be they are
just so overwhelmed with emotion and
these sort of visceral reactions to
everything in the news cycle that this
is just another blip on the calendar
they're waiting for the next issue so
that they can hop on it and it seems
like to me with this particular one all
i'm seeing on the political left is if i
can scream the loudest it means i'm
passionate and it means i'm right we've
seen it with elizabeth warren we saw it
with anna kasparian with the young turks
saw it with whoopi goldberg on the view
seeing it with all these young women
standing outside the u.s supreme court
crying their eyes out without even
understanding what this draft opinion
means it is just complete and utter
chaos and hysteria because they think if
they're hysterical it proves that they
are right and unfortunately well
fortunately for us it does not mean that
spencer you're sort of anti-hysterical i
think it's one of the reasons that
people dig what you do how do we how do
we win over some of the people that amel
is talking about you know the all of
these kids but it's not just kids i mean
it's adults that really are hysterical
right now we'll show you the elizabeth
warren video in a second how do we win
them over just calmly explaining
i mean not only
like the difference between a a
three-day
embryo and an eight-month fetus but just
the legal issues here and everything
else
well you know i i think it's exacerbated
by the fact that we have joe biden like
misinformant in chief getting up here
and and repeating this stuff you know it
really matters how the president behaves
in situations like this how he talks and
at this point you know i'll give him the
excuse that he's basically like a potato
with drool at this point but but it is
kind of amazing how it scrambles their
brains this thing because it doesn't
they can't throw any of the usual lines
at it so they're just taking the whole
playbook it's racist it's sexist it's
homophobic i mean biden was out here
saying things like you know this is
going to make it legal to separate
lgbtq kids in classrooms like sure joe
it's also going to make it legal to
throw labrador puppies off of cliffs
like why not you know you might as well
just say anything um and and you know so
that that part of it is kind of
distressing but there is an element of
this actually that is really hopeful for
me and it goes back to something that
anton scalia observed about roe v wade
you know back when it was was passed he
said you know by foreclosing all
democratic outlet for the deep passions
this issue arise arouses by banishing
the issue from the political forum that
gives all participants even the losers
the satisfaction of a fair hearing in an
honest fight by continuing the
imposition of a rigid national rule
instead of allowing for regional
differences the court merely prolongs
and intensifies the anguish i think one
of the things we have to realize here is
the hysteria that we are seeing is a
result of roe v wade it's a direct
consequence of how it toxified our
politics that's such a great i'm so glad
you brought that up go ahead go ahead
oh it's just so funny because leftists
will say that they want democracy but
they only like democracy when it is the
court siding with them on issues that
they care about and i'm like this is
actual democracy if you wanted to vote
for gavin newsom i don't know why he's
kind of an idiot and then some but he's
already gone out there and said governor
holt troll in new york but as you
mentioned at the top of the show dave
states will be able to determine what
they want to do and some states
including washington d.c which is
disgusting to me allow abortion up to
birth and other states like my good old
home state of oklahoma won't do that
because they value life and that's true
democracy and work and progress and i
thought that's what leftists wanted and
by the way
places like california will become
abortion havens and you will be have all
of the hollywood celebrities will be
able to fund nonprofits to bus in it's
going to end up being poor black girls
mostly to get abortions and then i
suspect after a few months of that the
optics aren't going to look so good that
a bunch of rich white liberals are
aborting all these young black babies
but they'll they'll keep doing it but
spencer really real quick i want to get
back
yeah
i want to get back to something you said
because biden did this really awful move
yesterday when he said this thing about
okay well then they're going to
discriminate against
young lgbt kids and not allow them in
schools first off
the briefing was written by alito saying
this has nothing to do with any other
case secondly putting that aside even it
has nothing to do with any other case
whether elito had written it or not but
also we have anti-discrimination laws we
have the equal protection clause we have
things that make us all equal that has
nothing to do with this yet we still
have this
mind-muddled idiot saying these things
like this yeah well that part of it i
think is just because they they now at
this point are just reflexively lumping
every possible prejudice together
they're not talking about the law
they're just talking about the emotion
there is an element as always they're
seizing on something real to kind of
weaponize it into this extreme hysteria
um and it's true you know roe and
obergefell the gay marriage
decision are not based on exactly the
same kind of reasoning but i have i've
been rereading the decisions you know
ever since this stuff came out and i
have to say that like i could see this
court overturning obergefell for some of
the same reasons that it overturned roe
um and
you think even even despite the equal
protection clause which really was the
explanation that you that you can't
treat people differently once states
make these decisions uh yeah i think so
because the the reasoning in obergefell
turns in part on
arguing that it's discriminatory to
treat a male male union different from a
male female union and i think that
underlying that is a kind of denial of
the possibility of telling the
difference between men and women and i
think that you know both alito and
thomas have kind of signaled this and i
want to read what they said because this
is also important to this question of
like letting the people decide right
about obergefell justice thomas and
alito concurred they wrote you know
several members of the court noted that
the court's decision would threaten the
religious liberty of the many americans
who believe that marriage is a sacred
institution one man and woman if the
states had been allowed to resolve this
question through legislation they could
have included accommodations for those
who hold these religious beliefs there's
a big difference between gay marriage
and abortion and that is the direction
of public opinion abortion has become a
more contentious more divisive issue
people have dug in their heels the
public opinion was already moving in
favor of gay marriage it's up to like 70
36 states by the way had done it exactly
every week another state was doing it it
was happening right and look i mean
you're gay married dave i'm going to be
gay married in three months um those are
not going to be retroactively annulled
the court's already decided that
decision
but i do think that this is another case
where
obergefell you know allows the crazy
people the crazy gays the peak trans
folks to roll in this giant tank of the
court and just flatten you know little
cake bakers and people that just you
know want to live by their religious
beliefs and and so this is actually if
that happens i don't get ahead of
ourselves but if it happens it could be
a good thing for us sane gays who want
to genuinely make this case and believe
we can in front of the people because i
think that they'll listen to us i think
we basically were winning this argument
before the court dropped a nuclear bomb
on it right and it's just so it's this
is what the left does with everything
they start unearthing all of these
issues that we've settled and moved past
on and next thing you know we're all
thinking we're racist again where
everyone thinks everyone's homophobic
again everything else i want to hit on
one other thing here before we show this
crazy elizabeth warren video which is
what alicia mentioned about they now
they want to pack the courts and to me
this is the ultimate assault on the
constitution they want to take one
branch of government the legislative
branch and now add justices to the to
the judicial branch to do what they want
i mean didn't these guys sign an oath of
office i know none of this stuff really
matters anymore because they all just do
what they want but i think
that they signed there was an oath of
office they have to protect the
constitution something like that
oh they don't care about traditions they
don't care about the foundation of this
country they'll even go and give you a
promise so we would never pack the core
that is completely wrong we'd never even
think about doing it and as soon as you
put them in a position of power boom
it's all gone and it really lies on the
foundation of what people on that side
of the aisle think about america and
about our institutions and systems
remember these things are founded in
racism and bigotry in patriarchy so if
that's baked into the very foundation of
these systems what do they mean to
anybody on the progressive left they
mean nothing they've always been a
system of oppression nothing more than
that there's nothing to conserve there's
nothing good about it so who cares if we
abolish who cares if we completely
transform them who cares if they don't
exist anymore they don't well speaking
of systems of oppression here's fake
native american elizabeth warren
i am angry angry
angry and upset and determined the
united states congress can keep rovers
to sway the law of the land they just
need to do it i've never seen you so
angry you seem to be this is what
the republicans have been working toward
this day
for decades they have been out there
plotting
carefully cultivating these supreme
court justices
so they could have a majority on the
bench who would accomplish something
that the majority of americans do not
want 69 percent of people across this
country
across this country red states and blue
states old people and young people want
roe versus wade to maintain
this number
and we
[Music]
all right so she's very angry and in
america today if you're angry that means
you're right uh i thought that the
question the way that the reporter even
asked the question tells you everything
that's wrong with everything i've never
seen you so angry thus the implication
is you're so angry because obviously
you're right about this stuff right
alicia
yeah i also am so angry and i've been
seeing and hearing quietly in my dms
from my liberal friends via text message
of how they actually are turned off by
this argument from the democrats because
they're like if they wanted to do what
elizabeth warren was saying democrats
have had power and they haven't done it
so you have women out there that are
even self-described pro-abortion women
that are like it kind of seems like a
political game at this point and then
you have other women that the one in
four let's not forget about this that
are like wait my miscarriage isn't the
same as an abortion and why are people
laughing about this and trying to
conflate the two in addition to that i
thought that women were supposed to be
independent and strong and better than
men except when men become us and then
they can be better than us except when
we have children they ruin our lives
forever and we can't live our dreams the
confusing message that is coming from
the left is really a turn off for women
and you saw in virginia and i think
you're going to see it again drastically
in the midterms where women are like
enough is enough you've screwed up our
life for the last two years you're using
us as pawns we're not going to listen to
you anymore yeah and by the way the
numbers that she quotes there i mean we
have some numbers here from abc news so
this is obviously not a conservative
leader
you know what well it's 50 this is abc
news 57
oppose abortion after 15 weeks by the
way 15 weeks i've mentioned on the show
several times this week that's the
the law that florida just passed a few
weeks ago it goes into effect in july 15
weeks that's three and a half months so
this is you can argue this is a roughly
moderate position i wouldn't even be for
it that long generally speaking but um
nobody no there was no fanfare about it
because people viewed it as somewhat of
a compromise it's not eight months it's
not six months it's not five months but
even here in far right florida with our
crazy homophobic governor ron desantis
we were able to do 15 weeks so there you
go spencer last thoughts
well you know i'd like to ask a kind of
a leftist question a question that the
left would of a form the left would
appreciate which is who whose anger
matters right who gets to to count as
angry does the woman who was bathed in
saline solution you know
minutes before her birth or shortly
after and now has cerebral palsy and
speaks so passionately against abortion
does that anger matter to the
miscarriages to the sorrow does that
matter i mean this is of course so
manipulative not because people don't
have strong feelings about this issue
but because of the the narrative which
all of the legacy press accepts that
only certain kinds of passions count and
that's why they can't put this back to
the states because they don't want
people to have that conversation face to
face
they never talk to the poster board of
women that regret it they never talk to
the um the survivors of abortion that um
are so passionate like you mentioned
spencer they never talk to the people on
the other side it's like loud noises
distraction and that's where the media
runs to because as we know they've been
this they've had this viewpoint for a
really long time and they only toed the
line of one side of the aisle so
basically what you're all saying is i
should have had three more hysterical
people on the show it's hard to find
hysterical conservatives
no it is
it's tough it's stuff you guys all smile
too much it's a problem all right well
we obviously could do this for five
hours but we got to move on to the next
topic so the the big thing of course
over the last month has been that elon
musk is getting twitter it's actually
happening he said it then it didn't look
like it was gonna happen we can raise
the roof it is happening and not only is
it happening the guy's gonna put himself
as the ceo this is nuts this is from the
daily wire billionaire entrepreneur elon
musk may be set to include temporary ceo
twitter ceo to his list of titles once
his deal goes through and he becomes the
owner of the social media platform
according to a report from cnbc elon
musk is expected to serve as a temporary
ceo of twitter for a few months after he
completes his 44 billion dollar takeover
of the social media company sources told
cnbc's david faber i mean the craziness
about this is not just that he got it
like that you know they tried this
poison pill it didn't work i think all
the lawyers of the shareholders were
like we're going to sue you people into
oblivion he got it
he then puts himself in the biggest
fight like the free speech fight which
is the biggest fight and now he's going
to put himself as ceo like
i love this guy um but there's a little
bit of like
man you're kind of nutty too to put you
know it's like he could put anyone a ceo
he doesn't have to jump into the fight
the guy's also sending us to mars and
building electric cars emily you got it
you got to respect the game on this guy
huh oh yeah 100 he's a very very busy
man and i was so happy to see this news
to see him by twitter and to now cmb ceo
is an amazing thing and i think what's
going to be super powerful about elon is
like
he's pretty likable for people on all
sides i mean he bought twitter
immediately is tweeting out how he wants
all of his critics to be super present
on the platform to say whatever they
want to him he wants to make the site
fun again he's saying his next endeavor
is gonna buy coca-cola and coke back in
it he's a very likable guy for
regardless of where you lie politically
and as much as the media legacy media
and all of these other leftists wanted
to come at him and say how dare you
reinstate free speech on these platforms
we don't want the bigotry we don't want
the hate it's not going to show up i
don't think and if it does it'll be
these sort of fake scioppy leftists who
are just tweeting things out from from
bot accounts and i think we're going to
see oh it really wasn't as bad as people
made it out to be and they got
hysterical like they are now with roe v
wade and we're back to normal again so
maybe i can't trust these people yeah
that's actually the point that's the
point i wanted to make alicia like that
concept right there that we're watching
these people go crazy about roe v wade
they're not sure what they're going
crazy about isn't that exactly what
happened here all the guys said is hey i
just want more people on here people can
say what they want block people if you
don't like them blah blah blah but let's
just open this thing up the way we've
all wanted it to be well those of us
that are roughly
it's only democracy if their side wins
it's only free speech if it's their side
speaking um it's it's elon's only good
when he's helping zielinski get free
internet to help their military
operations and people communicate in
ukraine but oh my god he bought twitter
now he's the worst again and he's the
fascist dictator it is so funny and and
i have to say like i'm much more
entertained by his tweets than i ever
was about donald trump a girlfriend i
were texting the other day and i'm like
for the first time ever i have tweet
notifications set up before i used to
want to mute the site now i am anxiously
awaiting every single tweet he sends out
because he can actually impact the scene
change that he wants to at twitter and i
just wish i could be a fly on the wall
to see the crying that is occurring over
there over him talking about being
temporary ceo i'm sure they're freaking
out
spencer is he sort of super trump in a
way in that he's the outsider he's the
rich guy he's doing all the things that
nobody else was willing to do and but
he's doing it in a more sort of calm fun
whatever way like without the grab them
by the you know what etc
yeah i think there's a lot to that and i
especially think the comparison is close
when it comes to how conservatives are
responding to this you notice we're
always accused of like hero worshipping
trump or whatever being slavish admirers
but most conservatives if you talk to
them they don't put their trust in
princes right we don't elevate people up
onto that pedestal and musk listen has
said some stuff about the future of
technology that gives me the
heebie-jeebies a little bit he's not
like you know somebody who believes
everything that i believe but he is the
man for this job what did we need we
needed a super powerful tech billionaire
to fight with these guys on their terms
he obviously drives all the right people
insane when it comes to free speech and
this is exactly what he should be doing
i personally am getting tired of so much
winning i mean he rolls in like the fact
that he's taking over as ceo indicates
to me that he intends to do something
which i really think is important that
he should do which is to fire the people
who think that he's a fascist nazi
terrorist evil doer right i mean never
mind he's going to let them on the
platform of course
but you shouldn't i mean all these guys
in news rooms do this thing where it's
like well my employees are staging a
walk out it's like great they work for
you fire them like it's fine you know
and i think that musk's uh takeover as
ceo kind of indicates that he wants to
take that kind of strong hand you know i
have my reservations about some of the
guy's beliefs but when it comes to
twitter elon take it to the moon to be
clear when he fires all these people i
can't speak fully for rumble and locals
anymore but we will not be hiring any of
these people i'm pretty sure i can say
that
um
this idea though that you know they're
it's consistent with their idea that
that words are violence but violence is
not violence right so if you burn down a
target in the name of social justice
that's not violence
but if you misgender somebody that is
violence so we shouldn't be that
surprised that they're so bananas right
now right
no we shouldn't be surprised at all and
i don't think elon's gonna have to worry
about firing them the brilliant thing
about leftists is they won't work for
him they will just leave and they will
have this mass exodus from the company
so that's what i'm looking forward to
seeing but yeah it's like alicia said
they'll say anything so long as it's in
their favor so long as it supports them
you know they don't support
vigilantism when it comes to citizens
taking the law into their own hands but
they're totally fine with vigilantism
when it comes to this roe v wade leak
they're not fine with protests and riots
when they look at january 6 and
everything that happened there but
they're totally fine when it again
supports roe v wade or the george floyd
riots in the streets everything is just
going to be wishy-washy so long as it
supports themselves and luckily i think
what's happening now is normal people
who are maybe in the center classically
liberal conservative who have just been
really quiet they're just sitting there
watching this all play out i think young
people are watching this all play out
too and go you know i'm not even even in
my puberty stage i am not as ridiculous
and emotional as this and i can't vibe
with it so i'm hoping that's what's
happening is that we're just having this
revolution in america of normal people
who go i cannot put up with this for
much longer a normal people revolution i
like that alicia i assume if they're not
happy they can go out and build their
own right that's what that's what
everybody kept telling us i actually did
it but i get that most people aren't
going to do it but that's what the
leftists can do they're not good at work
usually they don't have great work ethic
but they can go out there and build
their own internet right
yeah i mean i always thought that the
george soros could pay for those things
you know that on one hand they say that
they hate billionaires and we found out
that
not elon musk isn't the only billionaire
that pulled all the funds together larry
ellison and other financial groups that
represent other unknown billionaires at
this point um all grouped together to
create this fund to end up making this
twitter purchase
and we were told for so long go build
your own oh you get kicked off youtube
you get restricted on youtube you just
just go build your own and except when
people tried to do that then the amazon
servers told them that they couldn't be
on their platform and then now what that
we're gonna build our own servers uh
shoe on the other foot i feel like
what am all i said is so true like the
normal people are probably sitting there
going wait a second let if the shoe was
on the other foot and it was another guy
that i disagreed with in power how would
i feel about this and elon has tweeted
and said he's like listen i i find
myself like i want free speech in
general but i don't agree with the right
on a lot of things so i'm not going to
be an advocate here for conservative
values that i personally don't believe
in i think even tweeted that to ben
shapiro and so i listen like like
spencer was saying this is not he is not
our savior no man is our savior uh
there's another one up there for that
but you know it's important to recognize
that him doing this is huge and him
doing this is a good thing and i think
that we should encourage more people to
engage and do stuff like this infiltrate
and influence that's my new motto as
i've been saying it's one man verse the
system whether it's desantis versus
disney whether it is elon versus twitter
and big tech or whether it's judge
mizell 35 year old female trump
appointed judge who said no more masks
and suddenly we all ripped our masks off
that's what david and goliath david vs
goliath is all about all right we got
one more and uh spencer you mentioned
winning and uh this was a particularly
good week for that orange man who used
to always talk about winning 22
of 22 candidates that donald trump
endorsed in these uh primaries over the
last week or so uh won 22 out of 22. i'm
not a math magician but i think that's
100
uh the big one and we've got a tweet
here from columbia eagle of course was
jd vance winning the republican primary
for senator in
ohio and there he is pictured right next
to donald trump and we've got some info
here from the washington post former
president donald trump is flexing his
political influence in this year's
republican primaries backing his favored
candidates in hotly contested statewide
and congressional races trump has
signaled that he believes a key
potential run for president in 24 is
showing that he can still shape the gop
i'm king of the endorsements trump told
the washington post on april 6th and
just to be clear here so he got one for
one in the senate endorsements uh 35 out
of 40 so far of his house endorsements
have worked and statewide race
endorsements six of seven
and uh things are looking good for that
trump thing that what are they they're
calling it ultra magma
ultra magna i think that was an i think
that was a transformer ultra that was
ultra magnus ultra magga
is what they're calling it now spencer
there's something happening here with
these crazy republicans huh
yeah i think it's trumpimus prime
actually
well look i mean it's really interesting
to me reasonable people on the right
have disagreements about what trump's
role ought to be going forward whether
2024 is what we're looking at or whether
he's kind of this king maker figure but
i think one thing that these
endorsements show is that there's one
wrong way to look at this and that's asa
hutchinson the governor i guess of
georgia i think who said you know trump
cannot be the future of our party
because he will only divide us further
right that will be
he's this divisive figure um and all of
his issues these new right issues like
going hard on the culture war like trade
protectionism caring about immigration
and doing something about it right that
these are divisive issues i think that
what we've seen not just with these
endorsements but you know in virginia
and places like that that's the opposite
of the case the culture war issues are
the issues that bring us together when
you show people ordinary americans black
white i don't care male female i don't
care gay straight i don't care when you
say to them look these people want to
come into your classrooms they want to
talk to kindergartners about how they
can change their gender and change their
sex whether their parents agree or not
right people are appalled and we saw in
loudoun county how that galvanized uh
you know a red wave we're seeing now
that trumpism uh you know whatever you
think about trump the man himself
trumpism as a political platform is
hugely successful and i think that's the
direction the republicans got to go if
they want to win spencer i'm going to
clean it up for you before media matters
gets you it's arkansas arkansas asa
hutchinson not not georgia because
they're watching all the time and
they're ready to pounce so i'm doing you
a solid right there amelia generally
speaking seeing a little diversity on
the right the fact that there is this
internal fight uh this is good right
right again it's just normal people and
normal people happen to be diverse and
look different and think different and
we're all willing we're the side that's
willing to allow everybody to speak
their opinion and we want to debate back
and forth we want to come to the proper
conclusion and i'm so interested
interested to see what the next thing
they try to pull out of the bag because
we're winning and it seems like on every
single front the pendulum is starting to
swing back and i'm very curious to see
what their next attack move is because
they can't really go after and do this
whole orange man bad because he's really
not at the forefront right now he's
behind the scenes just saying you know i
like that one and people are responding
so we'll see what happens
uh alicia i sense though with 22 out of
22 he might put himself back in the
forefront of this thing that's what
pretty much that's what pretty much
everybody was saying and i was at
mar-a-lago a couple days ago with all
the crazy right-wingers of florida and
they were they debuted this dinesh
d'souza documentary about the election
uh 2000 mules was quite interesting and
i would recommend people see it whether
or not it makes an airtight case is
actually not even for me to say um but
this kind of nudges the idea that he's
going to jump back in right oh yeah and
people on the right like yourself and
ben shapiro are saying this and then you
have the new york times the daily they
did a whole episode about it the other
day which obviously they're skewing to
the left but he's not uh he's not only
asking people like oh hey what are your
conservative principles or are you you
know a maga person he's asking them
their opinion on the 2020 election
whether or not it was stolen and
apparently according to some insiders
he's even asking them would you support
me in 2024 i agree with what everybody
said that it's great that he is able to
have influence and the majority of these
candidates seem like legitimate
conservatives i just wish that he would
set aside 2024 endorse somebody like
desantis or nikki haley or somebody else
or maybe wait for a little bit and then
determine who he's going to support and
continue to endorse an influence and
maybe give some money on a pac level to
candidates across the country and step
out of it and not run for president
because i don't see that as being a
positive for the republican party or the
conservative movement i think it's just
possible that the machine would not let
him win no matter what whatever whatever
that means so it's like is it more
powerful he's bringing in more money
than the machine right he's got more
money in this last year than the
national republican party has so he has
the coffers to kind of support himself
here and he has those die hard fans i
just don't think it is enough and we
need to get biden and kamala out of
there and i think that there's a lot of
other reasonable candidates that are on
the national stage that appeal to the
republican suburban women that didn't
vote for donald trump in 2020. i didn't
in 2016 i did in 2020 but unfortunately
those female voters stayed home because
we are different than men and we don't
like to see orange man saying certain
things or treating women in certain ways
and there's great conservative
candidates out there that he could
support and endorse and have influence
and be a king maker without being the
guy at the center stage in 2024.
actually i'm not sure about this but uh
i didn't vote for trump in 2016 either i
did in 2020. can i can i ask you guys
that did you guys all come around later
i'm not even i was 16 years old
[Laughter]
i'm always the youngest person on these
things you've got to give me that i'm
old i'm so sorry you got to step aside
i'm the youngest and i have the biggest
hair and i know you really you really
got me on the hair i have a strict
policy of not letting people have higher
hair than me on the show you really got
me uh alicia i want to finish up with
one other thing because you had a little
drama this week you go to speak you go
to speak at a university you were just
going to give a talk
nice decent talk about free speech and
some of your principles and these kids
and the university not so happy with you
not just the kids at the university not
so happy with me the administration the
leadership of the university not so
happy with me um good on the kids over
at young america's foundation though the
principles of the university but they
had a queer pastor in lgbtq and trans
reading hours and were able to
interestingly approve a dance
demonstration within
48 hours when they sat for weeks on a
contract for me to be an approved
speaker on campus so i decided i'm going
to fly out i'm going to support the
majority the silent majority of students
at that campus that are upset with the
administration abusing their power and
only giving a voice to one side and when
we showed up there are about 80
protesters waiting for us chanting that
i was a bigot and a fascist and i don't
say gay um but i was like but what about
my gay friends dave and david anywho and
so it was a lot of fun we ended up going
to public property and i just you know
listened to them call me a fascist and
then once they stopped yelling in their
bull horn i'd ask them through my pink
megaphone if they had a question because
i wanted to discuss in dialogue and then
they'd yell that i was an old a b word
and then i would say okay but do you
have a question um and it was a lot of
fun for a couple of hours
and for more of that video people can
follow you on twitter where a bunch of
that stuff is and i'll actually i'll
give you guys a chance to pimp
yourselves out too amelia you uh you've
been fighting on tick tock what what are
you doing i don't even have tic tac what
are you doing over there fighting with
people you know i'm glad you don't have
it it's the most atrocious piece of
social media that has ever existed but
there's a new trans tick talker that is
going completely viral on the platform i
ended up doing a podcast episode when
this biological man had about 1.9
million followers on the platform he's
now above 3 million and that was about a
week and a half ago so this is how fast
people are growing this biological man
is being offered a sponsorship from
tampax so i just made an episode a very
respectful one talking about this idea
and whether or not this is the right way
to go as a society and he did not like
it made a video on his tick tock crying
about it and i have not heard the end of
the leftist death threats since that
very moment so if you guys want to go
and check out my show on apologetic live
maybe leave a nice review because i have
thousands upon thousands of hateful
messages from the very angry left who
don't like reality i'm starting to think
they're not as tolerant as they keep
telling us
uh spencer uh do you have an endorsement
from tampax
that's private that's personal
information dave we can talk about that
i'm amazed at the way women are bullied
online by men this is a serious crisis
that the left needs to address no but
seriously i mean i can't believe they're
coming for you and everybody should
watch your show because it really is
incredible but i'm supposed to plug
myself right also plug yourself what are
you doing
i'm sorry who's angry at you
everybody everybody's angry at me though
uh no well
one great antidote to the hysteria that
we've been talking about that alicia
experienced is to dig deep into the
sources of wisdom from the past um
there's not a lot of that around it's
considered sort of bigoted and
homophobic and racist and whatever to
talk about western culture um so that's
what i'm out here doing young heretics
is my show you can find it wherever you
get your podcast and you can also find
us on locals created by tech
entrepreneur dave rubin where nobody
owns the relationship between me and my
fans which i love so come join us there
you guys are pros and i think we're
gonna do this very panel again
have a great weekend guys i'm gonna
finish up for a few minutes uh direct to
the camera but good seeing you guys oh
and
oh alicia and amela i'll see you guys uh
in brea on may 11th i think you guys are
gonna make guest appearances at my show
with dennis prager and uh spencer i will
see you in nashville
sometime soon i hope yeah come out to
the south come on all right see you
there great seeing you guys have a good
weekend
all right so uh for those of you that
are
uh still here and and fans of the show
and everything we do uh today's actually
a bit of a bittersweet day for me
personally and professionally uh and
especially those of you who are part of
the locals community will well you
already know this because we we dropped
the info this morning uh but my
assistant helen who has been with me for
about four years now who has been just
spectacular at every level there really
aren't words to describe how wonderful
she's been we we hired her about four
years ago when when things were really
blowing up with the show and and
everything that i was doing and i was on
tour with jordan and my schedule was
getting nuts and i never knew where i
was and there were there were a million
appearances and everything was getting
nuts and i was like i need an assistant
and we had so many people been had been
sending us resumes and helen had
continuously and continuously reached
out and i had lunch with her one day
after a couple skype interviews first
this was sort of before the zoom thing
had become so ubiquitous and we had
lunch with her in la
and she had worked for rand paul she had
actually babysat for rand paul's kids
years before and she introduced rand
paul's kids to the original star wars i
was like that's pretty much enough to
get hired by me uh but she before that
her previous job was working for hugh
hefner at the playboy mansion and she
ran that for a while and she was just
joyous and wonderful and smiley and
happy and competent at all that good
stuff but i said to her at the lunch i
said so you know helen you got to tell
me like what's going on give me a story
about hugh hefner over at the playboy
mansion you must know some good stuff
and she said
nope can't do that can't do that and i i
hired her right there on the spot uh so
helen i i assume you're watching this on
your last day
and i just want to thank you beyond
imagination you have everything that
we've built here uh and i mean that at a
personal level and a professional level
you've been directly connected with and
we've built such an amazing team and uh
oh and i should note she's not leaving
because she's not happy or because we're
not happy with her
she has some some personal stuff going
on in the miami move wasn't going to be
quite right for her so she is leaving la
but she's going elsewhere for family
reasons and i wish uh everyone in her
family well um and uh yeah so it's a
little it's a little bittersweet so and
i also want to welcome my new assistant
daphne who is in the house she's right
downstairs helping out right now and she
just moved here from los angeles we got
another los angeles refugee so florida
just got strengthened again uh so i'm
very psyched to start there and for
those of you that uh play along in the
live chat uh during the show obviously
helen is always in there during the
shows daphne will now be in there
talking to you guys and sending me
questions and comments throughout the
show and everything else um so uh helen
we wish you well and we're gonna still
we'll still talk i just probably won't
text you at 3 a.m with like 100 things
that i need you to do but i guess i
could try that you probably won't
respond now that'll probably be it on
that note guys i think uh the show today
was a perfect example of what's going on
here we've got some wins coming uh if we
know what we're talking about we if we
stay calm and clear and concise i think
we can convince more people that what
we're talking about
are are the right things are the right
things they're the right answers they're
the right solutions and we just have to
be a little bit better than a bunch of
screaming lunatics
i can try to do that can you try to do
that
have a great weekend see you on monday